once the crew coming back two days
there's an upcoming Sony Pictures movie
called passengers starring Jennifer
Lawrence and Chris Pratt where they
mysteriously wake up 90 years too soon
on their voyage to a space calm they
just have to hang out with each other
for 90 years so we're gonna try and get
a sense of that today by locking
ourselves in our house for 90 hours no
phone no TV no internet me and Ned I'm
kind of excited about it I read all
these things in magazines about how you
should take a break oh this is a dream
vacation or just a recipe for divorce
we'll find out oh yeah don't need these
shoes it's like a little chilly outside
so I'm loving this I'm gonna rather live
I'm excited to cook more I don't often
have the time to cook so that should be
fun all I need to do is look up a recipe
I know we have we have much of it oh we
never use those I'm gonna do like an
Italian pot roast yeah
you know we've got stuff to do things
that I never actually have time to do
because I get sucked into the internet
hole hey I'm going to coin him
so you're organizing them oh oh why not
calcium okay
ergo I have to poop but I have nothing
to read well that was probably one of
the fastest poops ever yeah the best
thing about this recipe is it required
is it too early to start drinking are
you thinking what I'm even when I'm
digging hmm
kinda like that having your own person's
day one in the books
[Music]
good morning let's see how our Italian
beefs
usually met and I listen to a lot of
music Abba Greatest Hits Vol 2
yeah
it's really starting to set in now maybe
it's like the cheap lock box and I can
just crack into it you look it up on the
Internet I'm having it an okay time no
no it's happening at the office I'm
reading my magazine I don't know if my
friends are texting me you know getting
things done I can't kill time by looking
at news articles or football stories I'm
getting a little bit tired of this all
day long
look at that now I'm going to mix it in
with my occasion mmm and I shall empty
the dishwasher Hey look at us here's the
day - lets get our puzzle man get our
puzzlement on so we need to use about
tonight is fun oh really you I was
thinking Whitney's what
your psychopath uh puzzle is impossible
hey break needed some different we can
read or something doing to make up
maybe you were never like answer Larry
Johnson carpi yeah there's something all
okay second the way words to not have
your hand up here with a poop aerial
there's no one else I'd rather get my
foot stuck in the toilet with outside of
the plumbing emergency I think that we
had a pretty good time
do you want to exercise I'm ready to
take on these dishes Harold I can attack
this bathroom I went through all my pose
and I crushed baby die we're at a lot of
teachers oh yeah
tonight we're getting fancy
oh darling can I take you out to dinner
say around 6:00 we hit last 90 years on
a spaceship cruise ship I think we
absolutely could there's no one I would
rather spend 90 years with
I think I was just I had a moment where
I was thinking about what it would be
like it Martha tonight video is it you
yeah we are so happy to see ya you
remember the key your phone in the
internet are just ways to connect with
other people and when you're doing it in
person that's the most important thing
that's really
[Music]
with a life hahaha